why does apple manufacture all of their
chips on this one tiny island how did
one man at the lowest point in his
career build the best chip maker in the
world how could he do it in a country
with no track record in semiconductors
to speak of and what's next for the
company that powers the world today the
unbelievable story of tsmc tsmc warns an
invasion of the island would render its
factory inoperable we are the only
provider on the planet of this critical
technology xi jinping could feel they
have no choice but to use force in some
way to take taiwan back
i want to begin this story in an unusual
place the modern day because it's where
we can best understand the scale of what
tsmc has achieved for everyone who works
in technologically advanced
manufacturing two issues are causing
more headaches than almost anything else
the semiconductor shortage and the
escalating strategic competition between
china and the united states tsmc is a
central player in both of these dramas
the semiconductor shortage has several
causes supply chain disruptions
strategic competition a faster than
expected economic recovery tsmc like
many companies hasn't been immune but
very few companies can announce plans to
spend more than a hundred billion
dollars in capex when that new capacity
comes online it will make a big dent in
meeting global demand for the chips that
power everything from cars and consumer
electronics to medical devices and
military weaponry no other company can
really power broad industrial production
capacity like that secondly tsmc is so
important to the global chip ecosystem
and to taiwan that it creates its own
geopolitical gravity most analysts now
believe that china's incredible rise
makes some kind of confrontation with
the united states highly likely both
countries have raised trade barriers and
plowed huge amounts of money into
developing key strategic industries but
the semiconductor industry which they
are both reliant on is interconnected
here's a picture of how semiconductors
get made design happens in the united
states manufacturing is done in taiwan
but key ingredients needed to make them
are sourced from japan and germany and
final assembly often takes place in
china the supply chain is long and as
delicate as the chips made by tsmc tsmc
is so important to this globally
critical industry that it forms a big
part of taiwan's strategy of deterrence
against the threat of chinese invasion
in fact this strategy is so widely
understood that it has its own name the
silicon shield tsmc is too big to fail
it's not just essential to our cars
electronics and armies it's essential to
taiwan nothing like this was even
remotely on the horizon when morris
chang was born in july of 1931 in
southeastern china it's fitting that a
figure who is so important to the
economies of both china and the united
states today would have a personal
history so closely tied to both morse's
childhood was defined by war three of
them in fact first was the sino-japanese
war morris and his family had to flee
from japanese air raids in guangzhou by
the beginning of world war ii the family
had escaped hong kong however their new
home was attacked by the japanese on the
same day as the attack on pearl harbor
morris and his mother had to live
through shelling gunfire and later
japanese occupation by the time the
family had relocated to shanghai china
was consumed by civil war despite being
middle class by the standards of the day
morse's family was not well off he saw
despair poverty and injustice everywhere
he looked that motivated him to study
hard and later in his life to work hard
when he was 18 morris was accepted to
harvard he described his reaction as
sheer ecstasy and almost disbelief part
of that disbelief was because harvard
didn't have that many students who
looked like morris harvard was great at
producing social and academic elites
lawyers accountants and politicians it
wasn't as great at producing engineers
in fact it didn't offer an undergrad
engineering program at all and morris
already knew that he wanted to be an
engineer so after his first year he
transferred to mit and quickly completed
his bachelor's and master's degrees in
mechanical engineering morris was
planning to continue on to do his phd
but he encountered an unexpected hurdle
he failed his qualifying exams in fact
he failed him twice
so unable to continue with his studies
morris went out to look for an
engineering job the semiconductor
industry back then looked absolutely
nothing like today early transistors
were available but integrated circuits
wouldn't be prototyped until the late
1950s and the work was being done in
germanium not silicon it's not clear how
much morris knew about this at the time
he was a mechanical engineer not an
electrical engineer
despite this he accepted an offer from
sylvania electric products which had
just established a semiconductor
division morris worked at sylvania for
three years he worked hard but he
realized the sales team was over
promising and the product team was under
delivering when he heard a senior
manager say that we cannot make what we
sell and we cannot sell what we make he
knew that it was time to move on he'd
heard good things about a company in
texas today if you know about texas
instruments you probably know them as a
manufacturer of graphing calculators but
back then they were a juggernaut they
got their start making devices for
measuring seismic activity for oil
exploration that desire to power the
future of industry led them into
computing and semiconductors in 1958
morris received an offer to join as an
engineering supervisor with
responsibility for a production line it
didn't take long for him to score his
first win the production line that
morris was in charge of made chips for
ibm ibm was working on a product that
they thought would represent a big leap
forward its first mainframe computer it
used transistors instead of vacuum tubes
anticipating high demand ibm partially
outsourced chip production to texas
instruments this was the first iteration
of the basic pattern that would
eventually define morris's career a
company making ambitious hardware
outsourcing chip production to a company
he worked for ibm's own plant was
producing chips with a yield of about 10
percent let's discuss what we mean by
yield in semiconductor production
because this won't be the last time we
discuss it yield refers to the usable
output generated by a production process
in a process as delicate and complex as
semiconductor manufacturing small
defects accumulate into huge error rates
a ten percent yield meant that nine out
of the ten chips that ibm was producing
were failing it got even worse when
morris came on board the yield of his
line it was about zero percent but he'd
acquired some knowledge from three years
at sylvania and his own self-directed
study so like a chef he experimented
with the recipe after enough changes
morris was able to improve the yield of
his line from virtually zero to about 20
percent that's tiny compared to today's
top fabs but it was a big deal for texas
instruments ibm and morris chang
suddenly everyone at texas instruments
knew his name ibm initially thought
morris had gotten lucky but when they
sent engineers to talk to him they
realized this guy knew what he was doing
morris described the theories he'd been
testing and why his experimental process
had worked he wasn't just throwing darts
at a dartboard he was iterating
successfully by 1961 thanks to these
achievements morris had been promoted to
be the manager of a big engineering
section working on germanium transistor
development eager to support their
rising star texas instruments offered to
pay for morris to complete his phd he
accepted the offer and returned to
stanford for two and a half years this
time he passed his qualifying exam with
flying colors a few months after his
return the vice president of the
semiconductor division asked him to head
up an entire product department all of a
sudden morris was a general manager in
charge of more than 2 000 people he was
well and truly on the fast track one of
his signature achievements in his first
gm role was to complete the development
of one of those germanium transistors he
started working on after returning from
stanford texas instruments began
manufacturing that transistor at scale
to sell to its most important client ibm
morris had made another highly lucrative
contribution to the business morris was
moved from less important to more
important departments and by early 1967
he was the general manager of the
integrated circuits department the most
important semiconductor department at
all of texas instruments morris had
already made technological breakthroughs
his next breakthrough would come on the
business side in the late 1960s when
texas instruments or any other
semiconductor company began a new
product line it immediately charged its
customers a lot of money on the face of
it this was rational after all new
products required massive upfront
investment but morris with the forensic
problem-solving style that was rapidly
becoming his trademark realized this
approach wasn't optimal it wasn't
optimal because at this early stage of
production maximizing revenue couldn't
be achieved by increasing the price it
would be achieved by maximizing the
yield how could you maximize yield by
maximizing production volume morris
borrowed from his own experience to
realize that improving yields was a
learning process you needed to solve
novel interconnected difficult problems
he realized that the key to improving
yield was to maximize the opportunities
to find the problem and identify the
solution and the best way to do that was
to make as many chips as possible as
fast as possible basically morris
reasoned you always want maximum
capacity morris hired the boston
consulting group to formalize his
thinking the outcome was learning curve
pricing a model that sets prices low at
first in order to quickly kickstart
manufacturing volume and rapidly
increase production yields remember that
idea because we'll come back to it later
a happy side effect was that by
initially setting the price low texas
instruments was also able to grab lots
of market share morris had made a key
realization one that is still just as
relevant today sales and product aren't
separate silos they're highly
complementary you need a great product
but you need a great business model too
morris's insight and the work of the
boston consulting group made texas
instruments integrated circuits
department the biggest and most
profitable integrated circuits business
in the world
much of the credit belonged to morris he
had learned the technology and business
of this rapidly evolving industry better
than anyone in 1972 texas instruments
rewarded his accomplishments by
promoting him to vice president morris
was now responsible for texas
instruments entire semiconductor
business it capped an incredible rise
for a man who had left his home to come
to the united states when he was just
18. morris remained in that role for six
years until he transferred to the
consumer products division
and although it didn't seem that way at
the time this is where things started
going wrong for morris management could
sense that a market for consumer
electronics was emerging remember how i
said that today texas instruments is
probably best known for calculators this
is the kind of direction the company
wanted to head in the consumer products
department hadn't gotten off to a great
start but morse's bosses figuring that a
good manager would be a good manager
anywhere moved him over to the new
department it was a mistake the products
were different the customers were
different the market was different and
morris couldn't turn things around so
five years after being moved to consumer
products he was transferred to a job as
vp for quality and people effectiveness
it was a staff job basically almost hr
for morris it was a slap in the face
especially given he had essentially
built texas instruments into a world
leader in semiconductors this bad news
was about to be compounded perhaps
because of its focus on trying to turn
around its consumer products division
texas instruments was caught off guard
by a combination of an industry-wide
transition to metal oxide semiconductor
manufacturing leakage of talent and the
sharp response of its biggest
competitors it lost their advantage in
semiconductors the advantage morris had
worked so hard to build he could see the
writing on the wall from being the guy
everyone thought would be the next ceo
morris's career at texas instruments was
basically over he'd been put out to
pasture in 1983 he resigned 30 years of
service over in an instant of course it
wasn't lost on other companies that one
of the world's best semiconductor
engineers was suddenly unemployed
morse's phone started ringing one of the
calls he fielded was from general
instrument they weren't quite as big as
texas instruments but they were still
fortune 500 big they offered him the
role of president and chief operating
officer he accepted and moved to
manhattan but it was a total bust morris
believed he was joining a company
similar to where he'd just been the
reality was very different he quickly
realized the general instrument
functioned more like a private equity
firm than a semiconductor business
instead of growing organically general
instruments business model focused on
mergers acquisitions and either
incorporating the acquired business into
the parent company or flipping them for
a profit so after just one year general
instrument morris decided to leave he
was crestfallen here's a quote from him
describing his mood at the time after
these two setbacks at ti and gi i did
not think that my aspiration to be the
ceo of a major us company was in the
cards he was right just not in the way
he or anyone else could have expected
morris chang was in his mid 50s and had
a reputation no one ever wants former
rising star things weren't totally
terrible he was financially comfortable
but the phone wasn't ringing off the
hook like it was after he left texas
instruments however an opportunity was
about to emerge from an unlikely place
in the 1970s when he was still at texas
instruments morris had traveled to
taiwan a couple of times to meet with
government officials to discuss building
a manufacturing plant they clearly
remembered him because they offered him
the job of president of the industrial
technology research institute itri was
the taiwanese government's effort to
answer one of the most important
questions facing any developing country
how to sustainably raise its standard of
living remember back then taiwan didn't
have the first rate economy it does
today its strengths were in agricultural
products and low value manufactured
goods the government of the day was
committed to moving up the value chain
it knew that in order to accomplish that
goal it would need to develop cutting
edge capabilities and higher value
technologies like semiconductors itri
was established with the mandate to
conduct applied scientific research for
industrial purposes and then spin off
the successful products as private
companies in 1975 taiwan negotiated the
transfer of a semiconductor technology
license from rca a big american
electronics company it was about a
generation behind the cutting-edge
manufacturing technologies of the day
which were dominated by companies like
intel fairchild and texas instruments
but it was a start in fact itri was able
to use this technology to establish and
then spin off taiwan's first ever
semiconductor foundry united
microelectronics corporation or umc it
was against this backdrop that morris
was offered the job at itri it's really
interesting to hear him describe his
reaction he saw it as a completely new
kind of job in a totally different
environment that difference appealed to
him besides morris reasoned he was
financially secure he could afford to
roll the dice so in 1985 morris became
president of itri the early days were
not easy remember morris was a foreigner
he was born in mainland china and he'd
learned everything he knew about
semiconductors in the united states but
he was making progress sharing his
knowledge and transforming itri into a
high-performing organization one day he
was approached by lee kuo ting li was an
incredibly important figure in taiwan's
economic development after more than a
decade as economy minister and finance
minister by the time morris arrived his
remit had shifted to promoting science
and technology in taiwan lee approached
morris with a pitch here was the
thinking morris had lots of experience
managing large semiconductor businesses
taiwan's government wanted to develop
expertise in semiconductors they had the
manufacturing technology which they had
licensed from rca plus they were willing
to write morris what was effectively a
blank check besides as morris put it
this was an offer he couldn't refuse
lee gave him about four days to develop
a business plan no time to waste then in
an interview about his life which he
gave to the computer history museum
morris explained that he began by
reflecting on what they had in taiwan
his conclusion was very blunt they had
very little strength in r d none in
integrated circuit design not much in
sales and marketing and very little in
intellectual property what taiwan did
have however was a potential competitive
advantage in semiconductor wafer
manufacturing morris decided to start a
company that would fit taiwan's
strengths and avoid its weaknesses a
pure play foundry a company that only
made chips there was just one catch
there was no evidence that a market for
a company like this existed but morris
knew this wasn't proof that a market
would never exist in fact his experience
made him think otherwise
he remembered back to his time at texas
instruments where he encountered lots of
integrated circuit designers who were
itching to start their own companies but
couldn't raise the money the reason
investors couldn't envision a
semiconductor company that didn't also
make its own chips
in the 1980s it cost between 50 and 100
million dollars to start a new chip
company most of that was the cost of
manufacturing and those potential
founders who morris had met simply
couldn't raise that kind of funding an
alternative was to contract production
from one of the big players but not only
was that unreliable you were also lining
the pockets of your rivals neither of
these were great options morris thought
that a pure play foundry could be a
solution
by removing the need for every
semiconductor startup to build its own
fab maybe more of these aspiring
designers could actually form their own
companies and then maybe they'd become
tsmc customers he believed hoped really
that a new market would emerge it was a
completely novel idea at the time all
chip manufacturing was integrated the
few companies out there that did focus
on chip design had to fight for table
scraps morris was under no
misapprehensions everyone including him
realized his plan was a long shot but he
believed the concept had merit and he
trusted in his 30 years of experience in
the semiconductor business morris's
bosses who were the bosses of taiwan
remember listen to his presentation okay
they said set up a pure play foundry but
we know it'll take a lot of money we're
only good for half you have to raise the
other half oh and we want you to raise
most of it from big players like intel
or texas instruments talk about a tough
ask morris met with texas instruments
and intel but they couldn't see what he
saw so having exhausted basically every
other option he met with the dutch
electronics manufacturer phillips
phillips agreed to put up 28 of the
capital they also shared some key
information on the 1.5 micron
lithography process which was used by
the major semiconductor companies in the
mid-1980s some local businessmen were
also let's say strongly encouraged to
invest by the taiwanese government in
the end morris succeeded in raising half
the 220 million that tsmc began its life
with tsmc taiwan's semiconductor
manufacturing company began operations
in 1987 with morris chang as its founder
and inaugural ceo for the first four
years of its life tsmc depended on other
companies throwing them small orders the
dregs basically viability let alone
market dominance looked a very long way
away but then something began to change
morris chang was almost washed up it was
a brutal judgment after 30 years on the
leading edge of the semiconductor
industry but we're talking about a
brutal industry one wrong step failing
to turn around the struggling consumer
products division at texas instruments
turned into another with his ill-fated
move to general instruments a lot of
people believed that moving to taiwan to
try and build a semiconductor industry
from the ground up would be his third
strike after all he was already in his
mid-50s and trying to get ahead in a
young man's world all of this is what
makes the second act of morris's career
the one where he turned tsmc from a
moonshot into the world's ninth largest
company and a linchpin of taiwan
national defense so utterly incredible
it's a sequence of events that a movie
scriptwriter would laugh at as i just
mentioned four years in things were
beginning to change for tsmc morris was
working hard evangelizing cajoling and
just generally twisting elbows he spent
a lot of time talking to people who
wanted to start their own semiconductor
companies but previously couldn't
because they didn't have the money you
don't need a fab morris would say will
be your fap it didn't happen right away
technologically tsmc was starting from a
long way behind the industry's heavy
hitters but they succeeded in closing
the gap how before the emergence of tsmc
semiconductor manufacturing was
dominated by integrated device
manufacturers companies that designed
manufactured and sold their own chips
that kind of integration made the idea
of entering the market let alone
dominating it seemed scary for a new
company tsmc didn't go over the wall
they went around it in his 2003 book the
innovator solution the legendary
business strategist clayton christensen
explained that the natural trajectory of
industries was to move from integrated
architectures to modular ones
highly integrated semiconductor
companies by virtue of trying to do
everything were too big to be responsive
they were too big to succeed christensen
went on whereas in the interdependent
world you had to make all of the key
elements of the system in order to make
any of them in a modular world you can
prosper by outsourcing or by supplying
just one element ultimately the
specifications for modular interfaces
will coalesce as industry standards when
that happens companies can mix and match
components from best of breed suppliers
in order to respond conveniently to the
specific needs of individual customers
this is exactly what tsmc did
specifically morris enabled those guys
who he had come across in his previous
life at texas instruments to start
fabulous companies and in the process
engaged tsmc to manufacture the chips
suddenly an industry defined by vertical
integration because of its staggeringly
high capital expenditure and ip
requirements became defined by
horizontal integration morris had
succeeded in flipping it 90 degrees in
his own words from 1991 onward the
number of fabulous companies started to
mushroom when morris in his role as head
of taiwan's industrial technology
research institute founded tsmc he
promised that unlike the leading
integrated device manufacturers tsmc
would never compete with its customers
that promise which was backed up by the
reality of tsmc's business model ensured
the presence of something which has been
absolutely vital to tsmc's success
trust tsmc knows that it only succeeds
when its customers succeed its very
existence is built on that fundamental
compatibility of objectives the more
fabulous semiconductor companies that
were founded the more and more
businesses tsmc received its flywheel
began to spin in 1994 the year after
opening its third fab tsmc ipod in
taiwan at a 4 billion market cap by the
early 2000s boosted by cornering the
booming market for dedicated graphics
chips tsmc had caught up to its
competitors and surpassed them i want to
take some time to explain how they did
this because this is a really important
part of our story simply put tsmc beat
its rivals and put itself in an almost
unassailable position because it
maximized its opportunities for learning
firstly by making chips for a diverse
array of customers it needed to
constantly solve different types of
problems secondly the more chips they
manufactured the more revenues they
could reinvest in r d today tsmc has one
of the most valuable patent portfolios
in the world third despite being spun
off from taiwan's state-run industrial
research institute it wasn't shielded
from competition morris and his
colleagues knew that the only way to
turn tsmc into a world-class company was
to force it to compete with the world's
best companies last but not least they
are absolutely obsessed with iterative
improvements in its manufacturing
process semiconductor manufacturing is
one of the hardest things to do in the
entire world making the most advanced
chips involves literally thousands of
intricate steps across dozens of
discrete disciplines the slightest
defect in a machine or human process
such as a killer particle is enough to
render an entire multi-million dollar
batch worthless remember how i said
earlier that one of morris's big
realizations at texas instruments was
that the best way to quickly improve
yields was to rapidly scale up
production at low price that insight
learning curve pricing would remain a
core part of tsmc's success the
manufacturing volume that tsmc was able
to leverage relatively early on in its
history enabled it to generate more data
than its competitors but this story
still has a few more twists the first is
morris's retirement in the rush of
tsmc's remarkable rise to the top of the
semiconductor industry it's easy to
forget that morris was not a young man
in 2005 he was 74 years old he had built
tsmc into something that far surpassed
his wildest dreams so he called it a day
and rode off into the sunset morris
stepped down and handed the reigns of
tsmc over to his long time second in
command rick sai but he wasn't gone for
very long in the summer of 2009 morris
called a surprise press conference to
announce that at the age of 78 he was
returning to once again be the ceo part
of what brought him back was his belief
that he was the best person to steer
tsmc away from the global financial
crisis the other thing that coaxed him
back was what he called golden
opportunities ahead what do you think
the golden opportunity for a
semiconductor manufacturer was in 2009
that's right mobile after the explosion
of fabulous chip companies and the
advent of computer graphics cards the
smartphone was the third paradigm shift
in consumer electronics to take place
since tsmc's founding it was the biggest
by far apple had been selling the iphone
since 2007 at first it sourced the
critical components including chips from
samsung but then samsung decided it
wanted to make its own smartphones
putting it into direct competition with
apple apple hated that the money it was
paying samsung was being used against it
the relationship soured even further
when apple sued samsung for ip theft
that experience led apple to diversify
its supply chain and straight into the
arms of tsmc in september of 2014 apple
launched the iphone 6 which had a
processor fabbed by tsmc on its 20
nanometer process with just one
exception when it flirted with dual
sourcing chips for its a9 processor from
both tsmc and samsung apple has stuck
with tsmc ever since that's especially
remarkable when you consider the
potential risks of being totally reliant
on a single supplier to produce your
single most critical component but then
again tsmc isn't like most suppliers its
determination to meet apple's needs is a
great example of why tsmc enjoys the
huge advantage in chip making that it
does for one thing it changed its own
rollout schedule to fit apple's
relentless annual release cycle every
new generation of the iphone needs an
improved processor that means tsmc needs
to create a new high-yielding production
line every year it achieved that by
creating a modified half-step process
whereby it generated more modest
performance improvements every year
instead of bigger jumps every 18 months
or two years secondly tsmc is one of the
very few companies that can match apple
when it comes to capital investment in
2013 it spent nine billion dollars to
build a fab in tainan city that only
made chips for apple apple has rewarded
tsmc lavishly for its commitment in 2019
apple paid it 8.2 billion dollars almost
a quarter of its annual revenue securing
the partnership with apple was one of
morris's greatest achievements in the
third act of his career satisfied he
again stepped down as ceo in 2013 but
stayed on as chairman tsmc's incredible
scale built on a foundation of trust and
non-competition has concentrated the
chip making industry in the early 2000s
when tsmc finally caught up to the
leading edge of technology with other
semiconductor companies there were more
than 20 companies at the leading edge by
the mid-2010s there were just six today
there are only two firms manufacturing
the cutting edge five nanometer node at
volume tsmc and samsung both are
planning to put a three nanometer node
into volume production by the second
half of 2022 but before any of that
there's another milestone to cover in
mid-2018 morris chang retired for real
this time he was 86 years old it's
almost impossible to describe what he
has achieved the numbers are beyond
comprehension they're mind-blowing in
2020 tsmc announced an operating profit
of 20 billion dollars on 48 billion
dollars of revenue bloomberg estimates
it makes 4 500 in revenue for every
12-inch wafer it manufactures its gross
margins are in the vicinity of 50 it has
90 market share of the current 5
nanometer node it's planning to spend
around 40 billion on capex in 2023 and
yet the numbers somehow don't paint the
full picture tsmc is a story about
globalization it's a story about
taiwan's economic miracle and it is a
story about morris chang a man with one
foot in the east and another in the west
who built the best chip making company
in the world right now it's hard to
imagine tsmc being dislodged from its
perch even if tsmc were to go out of
business tomorrow and for lots of
reasons let's hope it doesn't it would
still deserve to be remembered as one of
the greatest b2b hardware companies ever
not bad for someone who was washed up
almost 40 years ago thanks for watching
if you'd like to see another video like
this just watch my video on nvidia next
[Music]